okay thank you very much
so my basic plan for today is basically
to
cover sort of classical material about
mark of decision
processes sort
of hopefully most of you sort of not
that familiar with the basics of a mark
of decision process otherwise i'm
wasting my time and so are you so so
here is sort of a quick outline of what
i would like to do
very briefly about the go enforcement
learning and then sort of dive into the
mathematical model of mark of decision
processes going sort introduce basic
problem  of planning and learning and
then sort hopefully time to talk about
what we can do in exponential size mdp
and i very much that we have time to
talk
about dp let see how we can cover out
this this should be more like a class
lecture if  you have questions ask if we
don't cover everything a good
sign both
lectures so reinforcement learning
somehow in the intersection of many
fields
ai probably sort of where machine
learning is coming from but it has many
roots in control operation
research there are also like
reinforcement  lear
cni
sciences the reinforcement learning to
talk about isort of related to topics t
well solid foundation and sort of
existed from the 50s as you see we
go typical application so application
are sort of growing rapidly this is sort
of a list that combines all the  new
stuff there is like can you can basic do
control
using reinforcement learning very nice
project stf about helicopter
control socer robot socer teams playing
in a competition also like the classical
things are both new and old
check the
60 doing deep deep learning in the late
80s and the new things are like go
pok not
yet sort ofw out of operation rese
classical
inventory scheduling
invent the main connection sort of to
us i think an important modeling tool
about thinking about uncertainty it
gives you a basis of how to think on
making decision when you are faced with
an
uncertainty so the main difference is
that what okay what would be the
objective the objective would be sort of
learning but learning interactions so be
doing actions and our actions not
to get rewards like it wasc talk but in
fact our actions are going to affect us
so we would like to dool of a large
scale stochastic
environment but our knowledge is going
to be partial and this is sort of the
uncertainty part that we have to c with
so it's important to contrast this sort
of  supervised learning or unsupervised
learning so in both of those cases the
data and trying to do the best you can
as you sort of we talk in reinforcement
learning what happens is that you
influencing what you going to see so for
example if i'm a  robot and i'm looking
straight ahead i have no idea what's
behind me i make perfect prediction
about what i'm seeing in front of me but
this is not the
right goal so in reinforcement lear will have
sort of not only to do the best  that we
can given what we observe but we also
are controlling what we are
observing so sort of high level what we
have the system will have a
state and the algorithm will really
influence the state so if my state is if
i a robot and looking straight  this is
what i'm seeing if i'm turning my head
i'm seeing something
else so the algorithm influences the
distribution so this influences both the
rewards and the observation
so there this leads us to like an
inherent trade which ex also in  multi
bandit between the exploration and
exploitation exploitation means that
doing the best that i can given the
information that i saw exploration means
trying things that unc about and maybe
give me higher
rewards so i have to balance the things
because if i don't
explore maybe  missing the
things ma
mod use is mark of decision
process let me for few define the model
and then sort of we can set up the basic
problems in
it so of decision processes the basic
element is a finite set of states a
finite set of actions  we have some
transition matrix probability given a
state action is the next
a compu scientist all know
deterministic automata this is basically
the model the only differ is that rather
than letters we make actions and also
get
the pict this is sort we are in a
certain  state we make action the action
we can variety of distrib
state
trans be sort of may the angle of my
eyes
ok and now what i observe is sort of an
input that getting this is sort of the
reward that i'm
getting give me  five minutes and then
let's see if i
can
so so now there is the transition part
the transition part is really defining
the dynamics of how the things evolve if
i'm a robot and i'm taking my leg up and
putting it down this is  sort of my state
ches
re in to random variable but for
simplicity and in in much of literature
easier to think of it expectation of the
random variables just think of it we are
getting the expectation immediately just
you be aware we can handle also r in
very smooth way so sort of what reward
can be
for
eh now we at the first part of the talk
yes at the second part of talk do
learning the no and the third part would
be exponential si and then will be
double no
so i think  you got the
answer try
explicit
what do we need to remember mdp running
mdp how describe my history so this is
way sort think about the history state
doing an action seeing re and observing
the next
state ch ac re ands
foll
inside the mdp of  you can to the state
more
than
et now we are getting a sequence of
rewards and unfortunately a sequence of
sort of very hard to optimize so like
most mathematicians would like sort of
to collapse it into one number and the
question what is way of
col so
do how
we what are we aiming at so first of all
we do aim like to have rewards early
rather than
later and then in some sense we can
differ system that is continuous never
terminates and system
terminates game it
terminates sy
return the sort of  how we up all the re
is going to be linear in the individual
rewards
state in state i'm doing action then
i'm transitioning to new state according
to a certain probability distribution
and i'm getting a reward which can be a
random  variable but for now let think
deterministic we can up for aite
horizon horizon h we can do discounting
which would be the most popular thing in
reinforcement lear some parameter g or
we can take an und
return fun part when you prepare sl
starting to
think for  most of us in think about the
finite horizon but almost all work in
machine learning would be about
discounted people learn
think about how many parameters you
need to learn so so maybe premature so
here you will learn the number of
parameters is a function of the  number
of states but the number of param number
of stat horon
hor
nic to
learn grow only number of state number
of
action number with the horizon
itself so aim maximize the expected
return for the most part i'm going to
talk about fully observable if  at the
end i have a few minutes
about what is partly
observable observable a policy policy
would be for every state to select
action and basically there is an optimal
policy so an optimal policy be optimal
for any start state so from now on
talking about only  the
discounted return
setting so there exists an optimal policy
it's going to be history independent
this you can see why because we ink of
process does make a we got as we
going to be
deterministic because it does not going
to gain by mixing actions you might  as
just choose a single
action ok just to summarize the model so
we have a finite state of state a fin
set of action we have a transition
function which is really stochastic we
have an immediate reward function this
is the the reward that we get for each
state action what we are looking for is
a policy it's a mapping from states to
action and what we like to maximize is
the discounted cumulative return so
basically returns come far into the
future discounted by factor of gamma
yes so i
could mapping from histories to  action
right and then pro that out of the
class of histories actions there is
always an optimal policy takes only the
last
state what do you mean see the entire
state you see you see the state you see
which state you are
in in a partially observable mdp  you see
only a signal which is correlated to the
state here you just know in
state and state is unique
yes
the rewards i choose state action some
people choose only the current state and
some people do state action state they
all
equivalent simple h you not  going to
get something about other not to have
much nothing not basically the entire
the does
need
infin so going to do i about the p case
mention infinite one
ok this is what ni did for me this is
very simple
casei think is
mul  basically a single state we in a
single state regard of what we do we
stay in this state and really
the
and there various models you can think
about if you can i think this model was
not mentioned so far you can be stochastic
like iid per  action finite
horizon describe sort of the stochastic
mark of process per action discounted
and adversarial
setting and this is sort of as much as i
want to talk about multi b now we can we
can start we
that given a complete description the
mdp so i giving the  transition matrix
and the
re and basically what will be sort of
going to be problem be always thinking
about the first
isy is find the optimal
policy the first looks easier than the
second but later
see dependent
another so let with the first
problem so what do  i want to compute so
really the intuitive value function is
the first one so i want that given a
policy def v of s this is the expected
return
this is how we get
state the second thing this is a much
less intuitive thing but it's going  to
be critical for most of our
understanding of
mdp function it's doing the following
strange experiment saying i'm in state
s regard the to do a
that of course a was the action that
the policy wanted to do
then q of and v collapse to  the same but
if it's different then we get a
different value and what you see is that
really this will guide us what is a
better policy compared to our
policy when talk about the optimal
policy talk about star we v star q star
and star
and  what like to is that it's not clear
prior that there ex such a policy so we
like v star of s would be the maxum over
policy for this
state so let policy evaluation so now we
can sort of the equation of policy so
what is of policy  what is my return
state s
so action this is return of this
action now i got to s prime sort of
distributed according to the action that
i the state i was in
andate to get this value sort
of
induction this is how i would like to
think
about what we simply a linear equation
if i write it explicitly down i know
the delta i know the r the unknowns are
the vs so i have a set of linear
equations and i can solve it and
basically for each state compute the
value if  i start from this
state here here is simple example just
to make everyone understand so here is a
very simple mdp here i put the reward on
the stat so have less rewards
let's take a discount factor of half
and let's say i have two actions for
state i can go after either up or down
my policy is a random
policy i wr the equation if i start from
s0 probability half go to s1 probability
half go to s3 so i really need to
average those two and my immediate
reward is zer so this  is equation that i
get
st s of wr down the and solve this be
the
value in this example
no yes in this example given a state and
action
deterministic
more complex
exam but think it's clear it will just just
have more terms here right but  it's
still set of linear equ
ands
easy okay optimal control so to
understand the optimal control we need
to understand really this function the
function ok so the q functions if i
want to compute it for given policy so
my immediate reward is reward i'll  get
from
s and then i'm going to transition to to
some state s prime and from that state
i'm going to use the value function the
value function of pi so those things i
already computed so now i can easily
compute these functions and  again that if
i'm putting here the action that i
really
for det
policy is characterization of the
optimal policy in mdp policy is optimal
any state the following holds the value
of the state is equal to the maximum
over actions of the q function of  the
state
acs the
equ
the easy partum there is a state and
action such that it does hold so it
means the value is strictly less than
the
value see it cannot be more the value
can be more than this chose one of the
actions soly
less  s do a
and then
keep the next get s the same
logic switch a and basically get a
better
policy is less q we are suboptimal
not we know correct we need
switch this be
understandable
only positively only posi
important so so the way to think  about
is you do it once you already gained now
you have this sort of weird policy that s
does a and afterwards continues with
pi but the next time you get to there
you comparing again the v of pi to the
so again gaining by
switching
ok  so for the other direction what we
need to say that if this this is the
optimal policy and the main issue is to
show that the value function of the
optimum is really unique and the way the
proof goes and i'm going to go fairly
briefly  on this is that we can define a
nonlinear operator which is
taking the maxum action re trans this
is sort of the function if this is
function and this operator is sort of
being with respect to it what we need to
show in fact i'm  going to show it in a
few more slides specific algorithm that
this operator is shrinking contracting
contracting at rate of gamma g is less
one
contracting contracting operator and
have a fix point and point will be
optim policy and the fix point is going
to also unique  can also show that the is
going to be uni and because the v value
is unique this there is only
one v value for the that can solve it
there is only one solution to this and
therefore if you got there you have the
optimal
policy
this  is not my notation this is what
the
us here is simple example of optimal
control would be right we start with the
same thing that we had before and now
what happens when we in s we
see if we do plus one we get 5 over si
if we do min one we get 13 over si so
basically what we can do we can switch
our policy to always from s0 to go to s3
and in this example i think in one step
after you compute the q functions and if
from each state you  do the maximizer you
find the optimal
policy
ok so now we want to compute the
optimal
policy three ways to do it the first one
is linear program most of
you probably would be more comfortable
doing it but let's do the other two
because i think  som no one really would
use linear program to solve
it two other methods value iteration and
policy iteration what is value iteration
doing we almost it in the prev proof
what does does the following
value function and every it iteration
maxes over the actions the immediate
reward  plus the expected future reward
and this is your new value function and
you keep
iterating this until you converge you
close
enough
yes
yes together the
convercy
policy
compute function and then given an
action we comparing with respect to the
function and get the new policy
out let one slide for each one of those
value
iterations why do we converge so let's
look at the distance of value functions
v star here assuming that we do
honestly we are updating all the states
so we look at the difference between vi
and v star  in infinity so what the
maximum difference that can
be so remember this is like the q
functions so let's see what's the
difference between v star and
q of s and a star this is
qi so when i take this difference the
immediate rem will cancel out and  what i
have here is the difference between
the optim this is v and this is sort of
what computed the
so this difference is bounded by of
course so this is just something that
sums up to one so this is bounded by the
l infinity between v  star and vi times
the
gam but i not interested in this
difference v star and
vi vi sort of max
basicos the v is going to be
less qi and therefore each iteration we
are shrinking the infinity distance by
factor of gam so the con be like  1
over
g polynomial depending how you think
about g think constant thinking
a parameter okay value iteration policy
iteration so what does policy iteration
tells us to do we compute the q function
given a policy we take the best action
from each state given the q function
this defines a new policy and then we
reiterate right so every time we compute
the q function and we are gray with
respect to it
delta delta to say how do you compute
the
function in the value iteration also for
now assuming you know delta let wa  not
knowing let's wait for the learning
part
convergence
the
can because when i'm greedy with
respect to the q if you remember the
proof there what what we said is that
each time that you are greedy you can
just improve compared to the previous
thing  so your value functions sort of
for every state you doing at least as
good as as you did before in fact you
can show that the number of iteration
here is sort
of you can relate the number of
iteration of value iteration and policy
iteration but notice that  the iteration
here
expensive now the point is unl value
iteration does con does stop at any
point policy will stop because there is
a finite number of policies each time we
are getting a better policy definitely
eventually stop and the question is sort
of how when do  we stop confusing thing
is that you can say that both polynomial
and
exponential one
slide so it depends on the discount
factor and how do we think about disc
factor so if you think about an
arbitrary discount factor then you can
show an example in which exponential  if
you think about the discount factor
something which is
constant then you can show that that it
really
converges polynomial time and i think in
the workshop in like f weeks yeah it's
going to give talk at least from the
title of talk this is about this
topic
ok
we about the blue stu so what i did so
far def the mdps and ied about the case
we gave mdp as an input and want to
compute
either
the value of policy the optim
policy
take this is more tricky you need in
order there  in to solve it like you need
to look at steady states and you need
usually to wr a linear program to solve
it
is so there sometimes you are not going to
have an optimal policy not going to have
values
yes
I think depends what call discount
count  parameter
not
want is
yes ok so now let's switch to learning
algor very much concern how do i know
those
model
describe learning algor do model bas
which is sort of the simpler one and
then talk about the model
setting for learning alor we are
interested in  the two evaluating policy
when to find the optimal policy and the
two approaches the model based one which
is sometimes dynamic
programming historical reasons and for
the model fre i'm going to introduce
something which is called the
learning start sort of the model based
one
approaches so the model based appro
is what you expect to do you build the
model and given the model when the model
is accurate enough you can solve it
given what i showed you in the half
hour you like to estimate the mod
observation both transition
probabilities  and rewards and use the
estimated model as the model find policy
so the only that you need sort of argue
at the end if i have an error in the
model they are not going to greatly
influence my
policy have a good
estimate estimated mod a good estimate
of optimal policy
ok
needy run for long we need somehow to
define what is long enough right so
during this time we are doing only
exploration we just want gather
information about the model and then we
can build observed model but what is
nice and simple here
is
sity the
re to get enough of
those
get learn optim
policy in a more abstract setting so
think about a simple abstract model then
rather than needing to build a policy
that will sample for us someone gives us
an oracle and we can give the oracle  a
state and action and it will sample from
us the next state and the reward the
question how much time do we need to
call this oracle so first of all we need
sort of to test every state action this
is clear but how many times do we  need
to test
it an accurate model of the transitions
right so each state you can transition
to each other state so you need a sample
size which will grow something like the
number of states times the log of number
of state in action per state action so
this will give you a very good
approximation of a transition matrix and
then any policy you will be able to
approximate well from
it on the other if just interested in
the optimal policy you can get around
l
number the optimal policy it doesn't
give  you uniform convergence the way
that sort of defined in the morning it's
not that for every policy you get a good
approximation but if you just in the
optimal policy good enough one way of
seeing how can you go from this sample
size to this you think about s
distribution
enough sort very specific policy in mind
that you like to evu is optimal
policy
yes need to go over
ac saying this is per state
action
multiply this by s by a i'm saying per
state action of course you need
information per  state action how much do
i
need how much per state action i need in
order to enough
inform
another
minutes clock is
speaking
ok b take break ok
this clear cheating this is i
thinking is to learn and do
reinforcement learning oncy algor policy
algor
oncy
to do to learn policy setting the
learning control over the
action and goal
isar
later
try
tos
we
ofc so what is real so in the oracle we
can just give any state and any
action get the reply but we somehow need
to reach new places  we need to reach
stat we no idea how
to it
split the state sp to two parts the
green part things that are already very
well sampled you fairly certain about
their transition probability and their
rewards and the red
part you either have no knowledge or
very  few knowledge you would like to get
more information in this
part okay so how can we sort of go from
the green part to the red part
hint this is a planning right so think
that this is really the high reward
states right this is nothing to  do the
real rewards this is imaginary high
reward states those are low rewards and
really the exploration is doing a in the
new mdp so the new mdp i do a guide me
from the green states as short as i can
to the to the red states  so this would
give me sort of a way to sample in a
fairly fast way
and i think let's take a break here and
then questions before we take a break
great one
question
oh if i get to a high reward
state what did i think of collapsing  all
sle
state and any action stays in the state
so i want to force optimal policy to get
toate
fast
rand do actions you might get stuck
somewhere here and you never would it will
take might take you exponential
amount of time to escape and get here
right so think there is like long line
with very specific actions that you need
to do to get
sing the pref one the
other now i need remember i think it
takes like n
cub can show here it's going to be
polynomial this is
definitely
okay
t